foreign
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 182 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather
heying we have had some sort of
technical glitch happen over on rumble's
end so we are streaming to YouTube today
hopefully these problems will be ironed
out and we will not face them again yes
uh this is our last live stream until
Wednesday July 9th no July 19th because
that would be tomorrow
July 19th um at which point we'll be
coming to you regularly on Wednesdays at
11 30 a.m Pacific
and watch out for a great guest episode
of Dark Horse between now and then uh no
chat today no chats from now on we're
going to be doing watch parties at our
locals uh from now on starting on July
19th so please join us there and we'll
be uh we'll be being active there in the
near future including having watch
parties every time we do a live stream
there looking forward to that it's gonna
be good yeah I think I think it's going
to be great so it's today's topics
include we're going to talk about some
environmental toxins
that are disrupting the endocrinological
systems and reproductive development of
amphibians
uh but we ask why some people are
blissfully assuming that that has no
reason to have we we have no reason to
imagine there would be any effect on
mammals which includes us
um so we're gonna we're gonna do that
and then you also want to talk about
chest feeding yeah I want to talk about
a number of things including chest
feeding but before that I thought we
need some proper evolutionary context so
there is a a hypothesis I am frequently
asked to deliver and I'm I've taught
about it to students but I think I have
not talked about it publicly about why
males have nipples a great evolutionary
mystery that has been pondered over by
uh by really everybody who thinks deeply
about Evolution so anyway stay tuned
that will be coming in advance of a
discussion of
um the insights that are now being
delivered on the CDC website oh boy are
they full of insight they're full of
something yeah yeah and they don't even
offer a nipple teasers like you do no no
this nipple teaser uh it's a one-off
nipple teaser so that's um yeah it's
bespoke
as I would hope most of them were all
right
um we are going to do a q a today after
our regular live stream you so you can
ask questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
and uh we're going to tell you about all
the other ways you can find us and and
such at the end uh except for our
sponsors uh who as usual we have three
ads right at the top uh from sponsors
whom we carefully vet and uh let us let
us truly let us let us go I can't speak
today speaking is only part of the
battle it's a big part of the basketball
97 but it's still only part of the bill
it's only by breathing so there's that
is what exactly the other three percent
all right our first sponsor this week is
brand new to us it's paleo Valley
paleo Valley makes a huge range of
products everything we've tried for them
has been terrific but we are going to
talk about I'm going to talk about just
one of their product lines today beef
sticks
paleo Valley's beef sticks are 100
grass-fed and finished entirely organic
and naturally fermented the meat in
these delicious beef snacks come from
small American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley makes
honest delicious products across the
board and these are just a few of them
while many beef products claim to have
been grass-fed off in the grass now
often the cows are only fed grass for a
portion of their lives
and meat can be marketed as
American-made if it wasn't really
packaged in the U.S paleo Valley does
not play these tricks their beef is from
cows born and raised on American soil
entirely on grass and these beef sticks
are truly completely fantastic they're
really delicious 100 grass-fed beef like
that in paleo Valley beef sticks
contains more calcium magnesium
potassium zinc phosphorus beta-carotene
and iron than grain-fed beef it also has
higher levels of several B vitamins as
well as vitamins a d e and K which are
understood to enhance mineral and
protein absorption
if you're thinking that paleo Valley's
beef sticks are like slim gems you're
wrong for one thing unlike Slim Jim's
paleo Valley beefsticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts
for another paleo Valley's beef sticks
are actually good for you ingredients
hiding in most beef sticks and jerky
include and this is not a complete list
MSG hormones hydrogenated oils and
brominated vegetable oil which if you're
wondering what that is it was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's in a lot of your food not if you
buy paleo valley though
furthermore virtually virtually every
meat snack on the market is made with a
processing agent called encapsulated
citric acid ECA which is included to
extend the shelf life of those products
but the health effects of ECA on humans
are to put it mildly unclear instead
paleo Valley beef sticks uses natural
fermentation which cut which gives the
beefsticks a long shelf life without the
use of harmful acids and chemicals and
with the added benefit of contributing
to a healthy gut
paleo Valley beef sticks are also keto
friendly a great protein Rich snack to
grab when you're on the go like running
out the door for a meeting or going on a
bike ride and they are utterly delicious
paleo Valley doesn't cut Corners they
Source only the highest quality
ingredients and are passionate about not
only human health but environmental
restoration and Animal Welfare as well
and they're a family-owned company try
paleo Valley's beef sticks today you'll
be so glad that you did head over to
paleoballey.com Dark Horse for 15 off
your entire first order that's paleo
Valley
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y.com Dark Horse for
15 off your entire order you won't be
sorry yeah they are really good and oh
good it is uh it is an interesting
experience to look at a beef stick and
not have to think what's actually in
that yeah no it's really fantastic and
beef stick made of beef that's the
Innovation here a beef stick made of
beef entirely organic spices naturally
fermented the beef is actually uh from
cows that were that we're eating where
cows are supposed to eat yeah from
beginning to end it's a great product
awesome stuff delicious and good for you
our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing we have friends and family who
have hearing loss there's a good chance
that you do too while we don't have need
for hearing aids ourselves we have a
good friend who does and we asked her to
assess MD hearing's newest product
carefully and honestly she did and her
testimonial is at the end of the set
MD hearing makes high quality simple and
effective hearing aids for a tiny
fraction of what most hearing aids cost
helping bring audio Clarity and capacity
to people who might not otherwise be
able to afford it
MD hearing was founded by an ENT surgeon
who made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford he kept the price Low by
simplifying the product removing several
rarely needed components
MD hearing's new Neo model that's Neo
costs over 90 percent less than Clinic
hearing aids and the Neo is MD's
smallest hearing aid ever it fits inside
your ear and no one will even know it's
there
other features include rechargeable
batteries that last up to 30 hours and
water resistance and up to three feet of
water in their volt plus model you don't
need a prescription which also means
there's no middleman another cost saving
measure MD hearing is now offering high
quality rechargeable digital hearing
aids for only 149 each when you buy a
pair that's 300 for a pair of hearing
aids here's the newest testimonial from
our friend who has substantial hearing
loss and who relies on hearing aids we
asked her to try this product and this
is what she said
I tested the Neo the new in the ear
canal hearing aids offered by MD hearing
I was a bit skeptical since I've never
liked the in liked in the ear canal
models preferring the stability of
over-the-ear sets they are surprisingly
comfortable and stable staying put
without coming loose even when I wore
them to exercise I tried the Neo in
several situations from Discord voice
chat to an in-person conversation in a
room with a white noise generator and
they passed every test it is true that
they don't have the individual audiogram
programming and smartphone integration
of my usual hearing aids but they have
everything else for a tiny fraction of
the price they provide an absolutely
stunning level of quality for pennies on
the dollar
so if you want MD hearing smallest
hearing aid yet go to mdhearingaid.com
and use promo code Darkhorse to get
their new buy one get one deal they're
149 each when you buy a pair plus Dark
Horse listeners receive a free extra
charging case a hundred dollar value
head to mdhearingaid.com that's MD
hearing
h-e-a-r-i-n-g-a-i-d.com and use our
promo code Darkhorse and get their new
buy one get one 149 each offer when you
buy a pair
our final sponsor this week is uncruise
small ship Adventures shouldn't that say
small ship Epic Adventures maybe I think
it should uncruise explorers by sea and
by land they have boats that hold orders
of magnitude fewer people than most
cruise boats and they take their
passengers to some of the world's most
magnificent places Panama and Costa Rica
Galapagos the Sea of Cortez in Mexico
Alaska even our own backyard the San
Juan Islands the small boats on cruise
uh uses allow passengers to get real
deep experience their largest boat can
accommodate a mere 86 guests their
smallest holds 22. these trips aren't
about dress codes or Glitz people
crammed cheek by jowl unable to
experience anything about where they are
CEO Dan Blanchard's background story and
Ethos are all impressive he's the real
deal and so is his company his boats
take small groups of people to places
that larger boats can't go and the
excursions are designed to bring people
into deep nature without destroying it
when we spoke we talked about the value
of wild roadless nature about the
environmental destruction that much of
the cruise industry causes and about
exploration and observation our travel
standards are very high in part because
we've created and led trips to many of
the places that uncruise goes and we
have seen firsthand what most tours that
most tours do not match the hype our
expectations were high for uncrews
though and on Crews did not disappoint
they took us along on a week-long trip
through the Inland Waters of Southeast
Alaska in early May from Glacier Bay
through the tongas national forest and
down into Tracy arm uncruise understands
that the boat is just a tool their small
ship cruises take guests through
communities locales on the ground so
they can have actual experience we were
blown away by what we saw and what we
were able to do 2 we saw sea otters with
their pups mountain goats Eagles in
their nests brown and black bears
puffins orcas humpbacks Arctic turns too
many species to list and mile after mile
of the most breathtaking scenery it was
definitely not a trip for people who
want to just look at the view from the
deck of a boat though each day we got
out into the environment
hiking kayaking skiftering and even a
cold Plunge at the foot of a glacier for
those so inclined and the crew and
naturalist guides were to a person kind
knowledgeable and enthusiastic the food
was surprisingly good as well the food
preferences and sensitivities were
handled perfectly and and every sailing
with uncruises all-inclusive
Transportation drinks Farm to Table
Cuisine daily excursions everything is
included on cruise is giving Dark Horse
listeners a fantastic deal 500 off their
current cruises an offer that you can
combine with other savings including
their last minute spring Alaska trips
which are already discounted so start
planning your next trip with uncrews
today and take advantage of our great
offer go to uncrews.com Pages slash
Darkhorse remember to save 500 on your
trip go now to uncrews.com
Pages slash Dark Horse again
uncruise.com Pages slash Darkhorse
[Music]
awesome
all right
um let's start by talking about
herbicides
yum yummy
um
I remember when uh it was
assumed
that uh if you were a person on the left
you were more likely to be concerned
about
um eating organic for instance and uh
and more interested in things like Farm
to Table Cuisine while understanding
that actual farmers were perhaps more
likely to be in what the mainstream
media dismissively refers to as the
flyover states right
and one of the things that we are seeing
Clearly Now although I do wonder how
long it's actually been happening for is
another reversal really by by many in
the mainstream media who are nominally
on the left or at least to still think
of themselves as being so who are simply
propping up big AG
big Pharma Pharma big everything big
toxin it's at some you know umbrella
level and with no apparent recognition
that this is what they're doing they're
acting like this is the obvious position
that people on the left have so
um let's share my screen here from this
is um the EPA
it is it is plugged in on my end
um uh so uh the EPA site uh talks about
atrazine which is a very common
herbicide in fact apparently the most
commonly used in uh in the US and what
the EPA has to say about it is atrazine
is a chlorinated triazine systemic
herbicide that is used to selectively
control annual grasses and broadleaf
weeds before they emerge pesticide
products containing after seen are
registered for use on several
agricultural crops with the highest use
on field corn sweet corn sorghum and
sugarcane
additionally atrazine products are
registered for use on wheat macadamia
nuts and guava as well as
non-agricultural uses such as nursery
and ornamental and Turf
epa's oversight of atrazine is dynamic
and includes periodic reevaluation
through the registration review process
over the years EPA is consulted with the
fifra scientific advisory panel on a
variety of atrazine topics well we'll
come back to that at the end of this
little review of what some of the
science the so-called basic science as
opposed to the applied science that is
the science that is simply trying to
understand what is true as opposed to
being driven to uh you know develop a
product or or solve a problem that we
know ourselves to have as humans some of
the basic science
has been for a long time warning of the
dangers of atrazine and in fact enough
so that we actually talked about it and
we recently responded to a question of
the Q a about this but we actually
talked about this briefly in our book
under gathers guide at the 21st century
I'm going to read this
um just one paragraph uh from this is at
the end of most of the chapters in in
our book uh which came out in 2021 we
have what we call the corrective lens so
given the subject of the chapter in this
case it's sex and gender what might you
do to help you resolve whatever issues
you might have that stem from a hyper
novel modern environment and and get
yourself back into a state that is
healthier and more productive so one of
our corrective lens points uh finishing
the sex and gender chapter in
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century is
um
keep contaminants away from fetuses and
children and several species of frogs
there is an established relationship
between exposure to Common environmental
contaminants like atrazine and herbicide
then an increase in hermaphroditic
individuals while sex determination
frogs is different than in humans we
will not be surprised if it turns out
that some of the modern confusion around
sex and gender ends up attributable to
widespread endocrine disruptors in our
environment and we have a footnote there
and a note
um
pointing to two research papers
published in uh
let's see 2002 and 1998 which I'm going
to talk about a little bit uh here uh
which is one of the research papers is
from the excellent Tyrone Hayes uh a
researcher out of I think Berkeley if I
remember correctly who I was lucky
enough to see at a conference sometime
around then late 90s early Arts he's an
excellent scientist and also a very
Dynamic speaker which always helps and
um
he was already on this this drum beat
back in 2000 2002. so here's uh the
paper that we
referenced in hunter-gatherer's guide
Hayes at all indeed he was at Berkeley
at least at the time this is published
in
um pns proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences
which for those not in the know if if
you care you can you can tell that I
figured that because it was communicated
by in this case David wake you have to
be a member of the National Academy of
Sciences to publish in proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences or
um be be recommended by someone who is
and they have a limited number of
recommendations they can make per year I
don't remember what it is
um but this the title of this paper
published in 2002 is hermaphroditic
demasculinized frogs after exposure to
the herbicide atracine at low
ecologically relevant doses
and the paper is excellent I'm not going
to walk us through this in depth there
are a number of papers I just want to to
point to here
but that title
says a lot of it right there
atrocene which we've already talked
about what the EPA says it is and it's
on a majority of corn crops and many
wheat crops and sugar cane as well not
allowed to be on on crops that are
certified organic but it spreads easily
as we shall learn through the air
through through the soil
and through water and what we have is
after exposure to atracine at what
they're calling low ecologically
relevant doses which is to say we had
been told that you needed High exposure
in order for it to make any difference
frogs are ending up hermaphroditic and
demasculinized after such exposure
now as we say in hunter-gatherer's guide
the mechanisms of sex determination and
frogs are different from that in in
humans but they too are vertebrates with
two and only two Sexes and um while uh
while the mechanism by which what sex an
individual frog is is not well in some
frogs it actually is but it's a
different origin of chromosomal sex
determination in some cases and it's a
environmental sex determination and
others
um
still it is logical to imagine that if
other vertebrates are experiencing
reproductive
difficulties and endocrinological
disruption after exposure to low doses
of atracine that we too should be
concerned about the effects on other
vertebrates
so I would just point out that there is
a question here about the presumption of
safety versus harm and especially when
you are dealing with a pesticide you're
dealing with something that is
biologically active enough to disrupt an
organism that is a threat to a crop and
what one hopes for of course is
something that disrupts a mechanism that
is so unique to the pest that it is not
disruptive of other things in the
environment and human health and
Physiology but it's very hard to do that
because biology is you know we are all
related and biology is conservative it
builds on mechanisms
that unite us and of course there are
mechanisms that evolve after are split
from a different clade
and you might occasionally happen on one
of these things but one should basically
assume that something uh effective
enough at disrupting pasts has a
likelihood of interacting with human
physiology in ways that are
unpredictable and may take a very long
time to discover if you have a system
that is immune to perverse incentives
looking for the evidence that it either
does or does not cause such a disruption
yes uh and indeed although the mechanism
of sex determination is separately
evolved in frogs and in humans the
pathways of masculinization and
feminization and the hormones that are
relevant in those Pathways everything
from the androgens including
testosterone Anderson diione to the
estrogens and progesterone oxytocin uh
the stero the other steroid hormones all
of these things well predate
the last time that frogs and humans had
a most recent I'm an ancestor so there's
plenty that is older than the most
recent common ancestor of frogs and
humans even though the particular ways
that it is determined whether
individuals become male or female
is are different let me just show you
show everyone a few more papers here uh
the very following the next year uh we
have Hayes again the haze lab out of
Berkeley
um atrazine-induced hermaphroditism at
0.1 parts per billion in American
leopard frogs ranipipians leopard
leopard laboratory and field evidence
um
and just the beginning of the abstract
here atrazine is the most commonly used
herbicide in the United States and
probably the world after seeing
contamination is widespread and can be
present in excess of one parts per
billion even in precipitation and in
areas where it is not used
in the current study we showed that
atrocene exposure at greater that than
0.1 parts per billion resulted in
gonadal development that is
gonadal dysgenesis and testicular
ogenesis hermaphroditism in leopard
frogs and slower developing males even
experienced oocyte growth fidelogenesis
okay so that is
um that is reproductive chaos induced by
atrazine at very very low levels in the
environment even in places where it has
never been applied in leopard frogs okay
uh that's a that's a such an important
and non-intuitive point is that the
degree to which these things atomize
into the world and exist at very low
levels that is to say you might not
detect them but that doesn't mean that a
biological system will not be disrupted
by them because these biological systems
are very sensitive to things that are
designed to be disruptive in insects
exactly
exactly so the other paper that we
referenced in um
in hunter-gatherer's guide and just like
really a side comment about this
is reader at all from
you know this was 1998 a few years
earlier forms and prevalence of
intersexuality and effective
environmental contaminants on sexuality
in cricket frogs acris kripitans
uh so this is a different species indeed
a different family of frogs these are
Highlands these are tree frogs and uh
and just here's uh
uh here's one true thing they say the
process of sex determination and the
influences on sex determination are not
understood for this species we are
unaware of any reports that Acres
crepitans experiences intersexuality or
undergoes a sex reversal as a normal
part of any of its life stages whereas
they are finding and they're
specifically looking at pcbs and pcdfs
um but uh they they're finding
intersexuality General again
reproductive chaos and endocrine
disruption as a result of exposure in
very low amounts
so I want to unpack a little bit of the
expectation here The evolutionary
expectation
you've got plants right a uh a
biological clade that has an insect
problem because plants uh are autotrophs
they take sunlight and they turn
the carbon in the atmosphere into
Structural Materials
insects don't do this so insects have to
eat something many of them eat plants
right it's one of the go-to things and
in order to eat plants insects have to
be able to withstand the poisons that
plants introduce in order to prevent
insects from eating them so in the
second called secondary compounds that
plants put into themselves in order
specifically to not be eaten right so
secondary compound if you're a biologist
and you find a compound inside of a
given plant and that compound doesn't do
anything in the plant it's not part of
photosynthesis or respiration if it's
just existing there without obvious
explanation the explanation tends to be
that it is a poison designed to disrupt
the physiology of herbivores especially
insects in order to reduce the uh the
amount of material lost to these
parasites
so insects and plants have been involved
in an arms race over this very thing
since long before there were vertebrates
I think that's fair statement yes yes so
the point is you should expect
plants to create very uh effective
toxins and insects to be very resistant
to them which is why it is hard to deal
with pests with insecticides because a
it's hard to come up with anything that
overcomes the amazing architecture that
insects have devised to detoxify this
stuff and if you do they have an
evolutionary preparedness to evolve past
the whatever defense you have deployed
and so those pathogens will tend to
evolve out from under uh the The Killing
effects of antibiotics
insects will if possible find a way to
evolve out from under the killing
effects of herbicides right so what you
tend to end up doing if you come up with
an herbicide that actually works enough
to be useful it tends to be extremely
toxic and highly complex enough to
defeat this system in insects so at the
point you've discovered something good
enough to be an insecticide you ought to
be really worried about the safety of
this stuff around other bile logical
organisms well but luckily insects are
an entirely different evolution of life
and therefore what affects them doesn't
affect us
would that were true would that were
true which actually you know there's an
echo in here of
um of Jordan Peterson's uh often
misunderstood point about lobsters his
point is you've got a very ancient
system that deals with serotonin that
this is a conserved molecular
intermediary in a process that is old
enough to go back you know so that we
find it in lobsters and in this case
serotonin turns out to be one of the the
oldest hormones that we know and in fact
the most recent common ancestor of
lobsters and humans both had serotonin
right so in any case insecticides are
heart chemical insecticides are hard to
produce why because
the world has been engaged in an arms
race between plants and insects forever
and that arms race prepares the insects
very well so yes we have some ability to
do stuff in a lab that plants have a
hard time doing but the ability to do
something worth doing that is safe for
other creatures is pretty minimal and
you know again bad enough if you have
regulatory agencies that are completely
free to discover the harm and forbid the
use of stuff that's actually bad for
people and the environment if you have
captured entities then you're just at
the mercy of companies who will make
billions of dollars producing these
molecules that are not safe for people
because they do work on crops and that's
where we're going to find ourselves yeah
let's talk about the capture after we
finish talking about the uh the science
sure so this still from this reader at
all paper from 1998. so and I include
these older papers in part because
that's what we cited but also to
indicate for how long research has been
going on that is sending up the signal
that says beware these are not as safe
as we are being told they are right so a
couple more uh pieces from the reader at
all 1998 paper
um uh which I have apparently subtitled
they're making the frogs militant ah I
see on my screen here for those who are
carefully reading
um sex ratios of cricket frog shortly
after metamorphosis strongly favor
females as was the case at the control
sites in study B however at the sites
contaminated by pcbs and pcdfs there was
a striking sex ratio reversal in
juvenile Cricket frogs resulting in a
high number of males so sex ratio
reversal uh is a stunning result as
um that apparently is emerging um
after exposure to some of these
environmental contaminants and then
feminization due to estrogenic and or
anti-androgenic contaminants has been
well documented in many species of
vertebrates
and they've got this is again from 1998
so these are all going to be older than
1998 references and I'm going to scroll
down and show you show us those various
congeners that's just various engineers
and mixtures of pcbs pcdfs and pcdds
possess a spectrum of estrogenic
anti-estrogenic and anti-androgenic
effects
we knew a lot of this a long time ago
okay so these references and this is
only a tiny bit of the references that
are out there but this very
article sites include number five
ddt-induced feminization of Gull embryos
so that's from 1981 DDT of course
famously is off the market but most of
these things aren't off the market in
the U.S it is still used elsewhere yeah
20.
permanently persistent alkyl phenolic
compounds are estrogenic that's from
1994.
a synergistic activation of estrogen
receptor with combinations of
environmental chemicals from 1996
reference 22 we have developmental
abnormalities of the gonad and abnormal
sex hormone concentrations in juvenile
alligators from contaminated and control
lakes in Florida from 1994.
reference 23 published in nature
persistent DDT metabolite ppde is a
potent Androgen receptor Agonist
and then we have just just a few more
and this is again not exhaustive from
1979 estrogenic properties of DDT and
its analogs
we have factors affecting mammary tumor
incidents in Chlor triazine treated
female rats hormonal properties dosage
and animal strain
we have an ecological study of the
cricket frog 1984
um diethyl still bestral associate
defects and mirin genital tract
development that's met that's mice so
now we're now we're talking actually
about mammals uh from 1985 and in utero
and lactational exposure of male rats to
one of these toxins
and
um I think and that paper is this and uh
it you know effects on spermatogenesis
and reproductive capability
so many people will have heard
tangentially or not so tangentially
about lowering T levels lowering
fertility in men across the world where
well you know one of the sets of
explanatory factors is is right here
so
a couple more pieces of
sort of expected oh go ahead and that
research was published in
1992. 92. yeah as you say we've known
about this for a very long time very
long time so
you've got insects most of which are
involved in parasitizing plants so
they've been engaged in this arms race
that we've been talking about
in comparison and you're going to help
me here as the herpetologist
frogs I should have brought my alligator
hat
well always yeah but frogs are almost
entirely
uh predatory
entirely is it one of these things where
there's no receptions are close to it
actually there's a a new piece of
research that I've been wanting to talk
about forever is a new speed the new
piece of work that suggests some
pollinating frogs it's one out of 4 500
5000 species of frogs well that doesn't
even necessarily mean that they're not
it could be that they're pollinating
they're going after insects that are in
flowers and they end up they may be a
riberous it's sort of I need to I need
to look into it let's just say the
passage
insect divorce there are some that eat
some larger prey but the point is they
are not herbivores they have not been
involved in this arms race with plants
for hundreds of millions of years right
I mean their second order herbivores
like most of us are right but the point
is the the insect surviving the
encounter with the plant then detoxifies
a great majority of the material inside
the insect and when the Frog eats the
insect yeah it'll get a little bit of
whatever the insect just ate so it will
have dealt with some toxin but very
little a tiny fraction of what insects
deal with so you would expect something
that is built to disrupt insect
physiology and because male and female
despite what the modern academies
claiming to have discovered male and
female go back so far in an unbroken
line of dividing things into a binary
world of male and female that those
patterns within animals that make you
either male or female and not in the
middle somewhere except in rare
disrupted cases which don't leave direct
descendants right so you know yes they
exist but they're errors
the world is divided into male and
female not only within animals but in an
unbroken way within Animalia
and the point is okay so you've got
mechanisms that are involved in taking
something that is going to be male and
going to be female and creating a
dichotomous World you've got plants
which can survive better by disrupting
something inside of an insect but it's
far easier to distort an insect than it
is to kill it outright right so
distorting an insect by disrupting some
process that causes there to be fewer
insects gee what kind of process could
you disrupt that would cause there to be
fewer insects how about reproduction
that will make a lot fewer insects so
plants have explored every possibility
here but the point is you've got to give
them a very high dose to actually do it
because the insects have seen it coming
from hundreds of millions of years the
frogs haven't right so the point is the
frogs are more like us and in fact the
frogs are probably more uh resistant to
this stuff than we are because cause
frogs eating insects do get a little bit
of this they're not in a direct battle
with the plants but they do eat whatever
the insects have consumed before the
Frog eats them that that does point in
the might be more resistant direction of
course the thing that points in the
opposite direction is that being
amphibians amphibians amphibios wherein
most species tend to have some part of
their life cycle and water in some part
on land
some part breathing breathing you know
breathing through the water and some
part breathing through the air if either
system is contaminated they are likely
to show the results of it yes so but I
will also point out though that we
actually don't know how that plays out
because yes you and I are not absorbing
the stuff from our skin unless we're
directly contacting it presumably some
things do oddly yep Across the Skin but
um presumably we're not getting very
much that way we're much more likely to
get a dose of it you know on an Apple
that we don't wash or you know you buy a
fruit salad somewhere and they didn't
wash it because it doesn't pay for them
to put in that kind of work but
a fetus is in a weird kind of amphibious
relationship with its mother and so the
point is the placenta because this stuff
is novel the placenta is not presumably
built to be on the lookout for
pesticides that the mother has breathed
in and taken a little bit into her blood
because that wouldn't have been a
feature of the ancestral environment at
least it would have been very uncommon
for nature to create such a an
interaction but a mother who breathes
the stuff in or eats materials that have
the stuff on it that wasn't washed the
fetus is in a very sensitive position
because presumably the one thing that
would protect it the placenta just isn't
built for that job in this case there's
no way selection would have built it to
do that job because it hasn't seen it
coming because it hasn't seen it coming
right
so um the story continues to get worse
oh no we have known research researchers
have been doing the research that shows
that
um atrocene and several other chemicals
of which I have talked about a few here
um definitely disrupt reproduction and
endocrine systems in amphibians at least
and furthermore there's a lot of
research about the Persistence of for
instance atrazine in soil and water here
we have
um a little bit bigger than you can show
my screen here Zach
published in 2011 we have a jablenowski
at all paper called still present after
all these years persistence plus
potential toxicity raise questions about
the use of atrazine
the abstract reads as one of the world's
most heavily applied herbicides atrazine
is still a matter of controversy since
it is regularly found in ground and
drinking water as well as in seawater
and the ice of remote areas it has
become the continuous concern due to its
potential endocrine and carcinogenic
activity
current findings prove long-held
suspicions of this compound persist for
decades in soil due to the high amount
applied annually all over the world the
soil burden of this compound is
considered to be tremendous representing
a potential long-term threat to the
environment the Persistence of chemicals
such as atrazine has long been
underestimated do we need to reconsider
the environmental risk so this paper
again is published 12 years ago
and here are just a few more things from
it
additionally recent evidence of
endocrine disruption activity of
atrocene itself and environmentally
relevant concentrations is cause for
serious concerns in terms of a
precautionary approach we believe that
the further use of atrazine should be
halted or greatly curtailed
atracine and its metabolites can persist
in water and soil for decades even more
than 18 years after it was banned in
Germany atrazine Remains the most
abundant pesticide in groundwater
samples I think I have one more oh no
that's it oh
um yeah that's that's it for for that
paper so
we know it's disrupting endocrine
systems and other vertebrates we know it
persists for decades after it has
stopped being used in the soil and is
found in seawater in remote ice so it is
it is everywhere and even in for
instance Europe which banned it a number
of years ago they still see it in their
soil so
in light of all that
let's go to one of our most trusted news
sources shall we uh this Slayer a true
Slayer of Miss dis and Mal information
yep who's this going to be um upholder
of Truth Liberty and apple pie I imagine
I mean it being apple pie with just a
hint of atracy just a hint of atrocene
because it's got wheat it's probably got
some corn if you it's got apples I don't
know if you were allowed to use it on
apples but you're allowed to use it on
corn wheat so and they do I am talking
of course about the New York Times Yes
um this week
man
New York Times this week the New York
Times published a yet another hit piece
on RFK okay five noteworthy falsehoods
Robert F Kennedy Jr has promoted
a long time vaccine skeptic Mr Kennedy
is leading heavily on misinformation as
he mounts a long shot 2024 campaign
thank you New York Times for protecting
us from his misinformation there are
five falsehoods that they talk about in
this article
we could talk about all of them we're
just going to talk about the one that's
relevant to what I'm talking about today
right so we go down too he has made
baseless claims about a connection
between gender dysphoria and chemical
exposure
in an interview last month with Jordan
Peterson a conservative Canadian
psychologist and public speaker Mr
Kennedy falsely linked chemicals present
in water sources to transgender identity
a lot of the problems he had said we see
in kids particularly boys it's probably
underappreciate how much of that is
coming from chemical exposures including
a lot of sexual dysphoria that we're
seeing he said he referred to research
on an herbicide atrocene in which
scientists found that quote it induces
complete feminization and chemical
castration in certain frogs yes it does
but the New York Times continues no
evidence exists to indicate that the
chemical typically used on farms to kill
weeds causes the same effect in humans
let alone gender dysphoria and according
to the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention quote most people are not
exposed to atracine on a regular basis
while we know for sure that the CDC is
either just wrong or flat out lying and
with regard to the research that does
not exist no evidence exists to indicate
that the chemical typically used on
farms to kill weeds cause the same
effect in humans well let's just see
about that shall we
my God okay so
I simply did a search on Google Scholar
for atrocene human health effects
I got many thousands of hits many many
thousands of hits
one typical paper
and I'm I will go to the site here in a
minute but um and I'll post this but one
typical paper finds that sure there are
some concerning cancers and
endocrinological effects that some
research is found to be associated with
atrocene yeah but it's really not that
bad after seeing disappears really
quickly from the environment and from
you and the research wasn't as strong as
it seems anyway signed yours truly I kid
you not the Society of chemical industry
that is who is putting out this this
work okay so here it is uh this is this
is published in the journal Pest
Management science okay Pest Management
science which I don't know if I can zoom
in here really well but you will see
that their tagline is where science
meets business
that is literally the tagline of the
journal where this piece of garbage
research was published okay so give me
my screen back here for just a minute
Zach well I find oh no here we go uh so
here it is here is their site the
society
um for whatever whatever I called it
Pest Management science is the
international Journal of research and
development and crop protection and Pest
Control look at that Banner look at that
Banner are you interested in receiving
this SEI Journal you too can have your
crops sprayed with a crop duster and
everyone will be happy and dead in no
time
I mean I have a lot more to say but go
for it well no I unfortunately uh have
to issue a retraction of a connection
that I drew in the beginning of this
segment okay
it's a weed killer everything I've said
about insects is true but it is not
relevant to a weed killer you would have
to do the analysis differently which we
could but
um purchasing is an herbicide yeah
um but the insects uh that are that are
eating the atrazine weeds are not um
are not happy either yeah right
so um there's you know there's plenty of
insecticides out there most of what
we're talking about is after scene which
is an herbicide
um certainly the again this is The Pest
Management the journal is called Pest
Management science it used to be called
that they recently changed the name of
the journal from from
um to Pest Management science from
pesticide science they just called it
that it was called pesticide science the
journal
um published by the Society of chemical
industry whose tagline uh is literally
where business meets science or was it
where science meets business I don't
know where science meets business so
sorry
um
so it strikes me I don't know anything
about this publication but based on what
you've presented about it it seems like
an analog for the phony fields
surrounding grievance studies right
you've got a bunch of fields that
pretend to be doing science and
revealing new things that we didn't know
about the way humans function and it's
it's what I've called ideal laundering
yep but here you've got business
laundering the dirty details of the
compounds that's pumping into the world
that and their disruptive effect so the
point is okay so industry has created
you know a a nonsense field or the
equivalent in order to make its products
look safe so that people can muddle any
argument that is delivered and you know
they they literally are creating the
journals in which the people whom they
fund can publish scientific research
that comes up with the conclusions that
they need them to come up with in order
to keep
dumping and pumping this crap into the
environment that we all share and we
know we know that whoever controls the
Press
controls what is published and in
science whoever controls what is
published controls what research is done
and therefore the New York Times naive
sycophantic Insidious and disgusting
claim that
what do they say exactly
um baseless claims about a connection
between gender dysphoria and chemical
exposure there's no evidence well
there's no evidence in part because the
the places that are publishing any you
know the research that would be relevant
here will not publish such evidence and
it's true I don't I don't find the
absolutely 100 clear research that
demonstrates this connection but then
those people who want to do that
research aren't getting fun day right I
mean it's it's
very much like in say 2022 when we're
beginning to see a few pre-prints and a
few papers that we're finding some
problems with the MRNA vaccines for
covid all of which to a paper said but
these vaccines are still the best thing
you can do for covet it's it's don't
hurt me walls in a different place it's
it's okay we're still we still believe
what you're telling us but we did find
this one little tiny problem and that's
that's the kind of research you're going
to get in journals like this and it has
a unfortunate echo in another place
um to the exact same pattern where
okay here you've got the New York Times
in exactly the place that the people who
used to read the New York you know our
parents who read the New York Times at
the you know the Sunday breakfast table
I
think the New York Times of course but
my point is at some point you start
reading the New York Times and you think
what the is this right but back in
the day before the what the is this
era
um The New York Times would have been
expected to be concerned about
pesticides exactly the food supply in
the in the environment Etc and the ideal
point is that expectation is being
disrupted here by a higher priority
right yeah the corruption of the
democratic party must be maintained
against anything that threatens it and
Bobby Kennedy Jr threatens it and so the
point is the New York Times will now uh
Embrace whatever position undermines
Bobby Kennedy even when his position
would be a traditionally liberal
position so hold on the echo is that
this sounds a lot like Eric topel who
actually fought to delay the release of
the vaccine so that Trump wouldn't get
credit for that right the point is oh
Eric tople who's so very concerned about
people suffering from from covid was
actually cynically delaying this thing
for political reasons here you've got
the New York Times cynically uh
disrupting a obvious argument about the
hazards of pesticides for political
reasons and the point is well is
anything sacred is there any principle
that you will adhere to even when
somebody that you politically fear uh
you know says it right right yeah and
yeah it's it's even worse than that but
I think Zach has something to say yes
well someone in the chat reminded me you
will want to remember dad that Kennedy's
term for these idea laundering
scientists is by altitudes
absolutely it's not science it's paid
they paid service to create a scientific
article for something it is what it is
yeah to create an illusion of science
yes
um
so okay Europe actually banned the
European Union banned after scene back
in 2003.
uh that's 20 years ago
and here's show my screen uh one more
time here this is a 2006 article
um co-published by a research scientist
and a lawyer European Union bans
atrocene while the United States
negotiates continued use so it was
banned in 2003 this paper is published
in 2006 it begins atrazine is a common
agricultural herbicide with endocrine
disrupter activity they just flatly
state it there is evidence that it
interferes with reproduction and
development and may cause cancer there
is and the industry-sponsored research
says that it's not that important yeah
yeah we don't we don't really think it
matters but um I don't know why
although the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency EPA approved its
continued use in October 2003 of the
same month the European Union announced
a ban of atrocene because if ubiquitous
and unpreventable water contamination
the authors of this paper and I'm not
going to read through all of it but the
authors of this paper reviewed
regulatory procedures and government
documents and Report efforts by the
manufacturer of atracy in syngenta to
influence the U.S atrazine assessment by
submitting flawed scientific data as
evidence of no harm and by meeting
repeatedly and privately with EPA to
negotiate the government's regulatory
approach many of the details of these
negotiations continue to be withheld
from the public despite EPA regulations
and Federal open government laws that
require assessed decisions to be made in
the open
one more little piece from this paper
despite statutory requirements the
agency advisory committees must be
objective and publicly transparent EPA
officials held approximately 50 5-0
private meetings
with syngenta regarding atrazine in 2003
EPA established and utilized two
advisory committees composed only of
Representatives of syngenta and EPA
without any public representation
epa's 2003 approval of atrocene relied
on the final recommendations of these
two committees characterized by EPA as
joint efforts between EPA and sugenta to
determine how atrazine should be
regulated and where it should be
monitored
yeah that so we're
those those of us in the public who
continue to think
that the people whose job title suggests
that they are looking out for us that
they care about public health that they
recognize that their job in public
health is about actually protecting the
Public's Health as opposed to the
profits of Corporations
those people who still believe that need
to wake up
this has been going on for a very long
time
and for a very long time there's been no
one watching out for what's in our food
what's on our crops what's in our water
what's in our air we have the Regulatory
Agencies
but they're doing exactly the opposite
of what they're supposed to be doing
yeah we don't I mean it's a subtle
distinction we don't have the regulatory
agency so what we have is something that
has hollowed them out and left them
there so that we don't even you know if
you knew as we know when we travel in
other parts of the world right there's
nothing protecting us we can at least
take some steps to protect ourselves but
when you have something that is
ostensibly doing the job that is
specifically not doing the job in fact
it's doing the inverse of the job
you get the danger of the false sense of
security and the full exposure to this
stuff
I'm reminded of
um what I used to say and then when we
taught study abroad together what we
used to say
to students before taking them out of
the country
um and it's a it's an unintuitive point
which is that you know we're going to a
land with much many fewer lawyers than
the land in which you grew up and
therefore you have to take greater
responsibility for your own safety and I
wonder if you want to explore that a
little bit because I I think it's it's
relevant here precisely because what we
are finding is that cryptically on
actually the the most important issues
we here in the weird world including the
US have been living in a land
effectively without regulation forever
even though we don't have like the
Gringo traps the giant potholes that you
might find on the street in Venezuela
that makes sense yeah so let me let me
lay out a bit of the framework here
you have a system in which lawyers are
empowered to find harm to find causes of
action and to pursue it in a court on
behalf of a class or an individual who's
been harmed
that can result in a very uh unpleasant
relationship with lawyers because
they're constantly looking for
opportunity but the point is that system
in which lawyers are empowered to get
paid for doing this
does do a good job of discovering
connections that can be established well
enough for a court to see them and to
recognize them as
as justifying of a remedy yes
so we have a system that has been very
safe what Heather's calling a gringo
trap it's a joke the joke is if you're
in Latin America sometimes you will find
a hole in the sidewalk often with rebar
sticking out of it right and the idea is
that you know any person who's grown up
in such an environment is not on their
phone in danger of falling into one of
these things because actually they've
been trained that the sidewalk isn't as
safe as it might be but an environment
where you got lawyers looking for causes
of action the sidewalks tend to be
pretty safe right so there is this
expectation of safety that is now
completely out of phase for anything
subtle or delayed right there's an
obsession with our safety at the
instantaneous level and a complete
indifference to our safety in the long
term right hence the madness surrounding
mRNA vaccines which were obviously a
danger whose full extent we couldn't
know for decades
right and over an obsession with respect
to covet in the in the moment this
comparison results in a complete
complete mismapping by citizens who feel
the you know the nanny State trying to
protect them from little things all the
time they don't realize what benefit
they get from it but they also don't
realize it does not correctly predict
how well protected you are from subtle
things right they can shorten your life
they can cause your children to have
terrible deformities and you can't prove
the connection so they don't get dealt
with
um and and it's no it's it's no one's
job to deal with those things the
Regulatory Agencies would have a very
difficult even if they were actually
doing what they are supposed to be
trying to do would have a very hard time
establishing causality uh the
politicians who would go after this are
going to be long out of office before
anything changes and you know frankly
it's part it's it's it's a big part of
the appeal of RFK which is that uh you
know he is he is staunchly pro-human and
pro-environment and has been for a very
long time and is willing to look deep
into what long-term trends are and say
you know what
it's not that I'm saying you can't ever
put stuff on your crops or you can't
ever vaccinate your children
it's that we deserve to have those
processes and products be safety tested
before we do so like why how did we end
up reversing how did we end up making
the default position be we're going to
add anything we want and we're going to
inject anything we want and we're going
to have you take anything we want you to
take
and the burden is on you to prove that
it's not okay
in order to opt out as opposed to the
default assumption is opt out don't put
that on my food don't put that in my
body until you've actually done the
safety testing that needs to be done so
we have the wrong presumption you also
have to establish these things in a
slanted academic environment right so
and I want to pick up on the concept of
opting out because it's really the
central one here right let's suppose
that you and I as biologists look at
this when we say oh
there's no way that's safe there's no
way that's safe it is to fundamentally
disruptive of biology that is
long-standing ETC I don't want any part
of it I certainly don't want my kids to
have any part of it I want out yep you
can't even opt out that's right what
would you have to do to substantially
opt out well you'd have to stop eating
in restaurants maybe you'd have to keep
your windows closed and filter the air
right you can't you can't control what
people are spraying on their crops and
opt out you know the point is these
processes don't know boundaries
diffusion happens the stuff persists way
longer than we think it does it moves
around on animals who don't know that
they shouldn't be eating something that
was just sprayed so there is no way to
fully opt out at all you can spend a
huge effort and a lot of money reducing
your exposure which we do right we do
this and the point is how effective do
we actually live for decades right so
you know yes you can spend more for
organic food right and there's a huge
push there's a huge
presumably industry-sponsored push to
make fun of people who insist on eating
organic there's no demonstrated benefit
from eating organic there's no
nutritional difference we didn't say
nutritional difference we said a hazard
and I also don't believe that right I
don't really believe it either because
for lots of reasons for one thing uh you
know a Roundup Ready crop has you know
trade-off wise been compromised in order
to induce this one characteristic that's
agriculturally desirable at a financial
level so yes there will be nutritional
differences but it doesn't matter if
they're nutritional differences what if
I don't want Parkinson's disease and I
suspect that pesticides are involved in
creating Parkinson's disease how much do
I have to alter my life to really
eliminate those things
radically it's just not possible to do
it completely and to do it substantially
is a radical increase in your expenses
and it shouldn't be this way the fact is
the presumption and you know we can get
into the uh the precautionary principle
the precautionary principle
is logically the right thing it is a bit
difficult to instantiate well it can be
taken to an extreme it could be onerous
it can be onerous but
logically speaking it's the Baseline
right these things are dangerous until
proven safe and not the other way around
you will never get there in a world
where the those who have a perverse
incentive can gain control over the
academic environment over uh the
legislative environment Over The
Regulators right you just can't get
there because their perverse incentive
is concentrated they can disrupt our
ability to exert a rational uh control
mechanism every time and it's what they
do and it's making us uh it's making us
unsafe and we have no idea how much of
the obvious ill health that the
citizenry experiences you just stand on
the street corner stand in an airport
watch people go by yes they are living
longer how healthy do they look what is
causing that right we cannot protect
people from this as long as the
industries that make the profit have so
much say over what the regulations look
like and yes that's a very boring and
tired point but it's never going to be
untrue yeah right it's fundamental no
and in this we've said this before uh
and many others have as well but uh
we've become ugly
we put and and that this is just one
admittedly subjective at the holistic
level measure of our Collective ill
health but
when we were growing up
most everyone was attractive
and more so even in the 50s
right
and it's not true anymore and it's it's
sad and this is this is not an attack on
the individuals who find themselves
having been you know maimed is the right
term maimed having been you know birthed
into a world where there there are not
the full set of choices to actually opt
out
uh when what we all should have been
allowed to do was choose whether to opt
in and we have been disallowed from that
across domain after domain after domain
speaking of which yes
you want to talk about chest feeding oh
no I wanted to talk about uh nipples
first okay so
um we are regularly asked as
evolutionary biologists what is the
explanation for male nipples and frankly
I love the question
many I will I would just say that um I
as a female evolutionary biologist I've
been asked that question probably less
than five times and you have been asked
that question a lot in part because you
say like you you know that you've think
about it and you have an idea and all
this but um I do believe that this is
more likely to be a question asked well
a man with nipples
it's liable to be asked a lot of a man
without nipples but they don't exist so
we can't test that hypothesis it exists
thought it's not the alternative
hypothesis and you know it I do
um all right but let's uh let us so
let's just say uh many in fact I think
all evolutionary biologists have
pondered this question at some point and
it's a wonderful one which intersects
very well
with a concept
I don't want to drag people too deep
into the weeds but yes you do decades
ago uh I came up with an Adaptive test a
test to see whether a particular feature
of organisms should be presumed to be a
product of adaptive Evolution or not and
the reason I came up with that was not
because this wasn't obvious I thought it
was obvious but because there was a
battle in evolutionary biology over the
question of whether evolutionary
biologists were leaping to conclusions
imagining that various features of
organisms were the result of adaptation
when maybe you know there are lots of
other evolutionary processes could it
perhaps be the result
of drift or whatever
um so anyway I came up with a test to
free myself from that stupid question
which disrupts everything if you let it
get away from you and the test basically
you just uh make a lot of arm gestures
while you describe it oh you want me to
do a lot of arm away like you should
okay
um the test involves it's it's a
conservative test it will miss some
things that are actually the result of
adaptive Evolution and it is not a
hundred percent conclusive it will
lead you to the correct presumption if
you apply the test correctly and it is
conservative uh in a it's got to
Fail-Safe in it so it basically asks
whether several characteristics can be
found inside of a particular trait so
let's say we're talking about the um I
should have gotten a
image for this but there is a an extinct
reptile a a dinosaur Epoch reptile
called a polycosaur
which has a sale on its back this was a
clay there were lots of different
palicosaurs but anyway Heather will
bring up a picture of a palicosaur
so these animals had a sale on their
back we don't know what the sale was for
because there are no polycosaurs that we
can observe or you know bring to the
laboratory or anything like that so we
are left with this structure and no
ability to run a test in the present on
what it does
so my point is yeah it's true that we
don't know what it what it does one
example of something it might do it
might be a solar panel that allows these
animals to warm their blood by turning
that sail towards the Sun but again we
can't observe them so we don't know but
my point is that question the mystery
surrounding what the sale on the back of
obligosaur does is not the same question
as whether or not it is the product of
adaptive Evolution obviously it's the
product of adaptive Evolution and the
test to show that this is the the
correct presumption is does it involve
high levels of complexity biology
adaptive evolution is the only process
that creates high levels of complexity
so is this complex yes there will have
been a developmental pathway that has
produced this polecosaur
replica Source sale you know it has a
structure it has bones it has skin all
of these things that we can still detect
in the fossils so it has complexity it
has an expense it's made out of
materials right materials that could be
redirected materials and energy that
could be redirected to something else
that would enhance the fitness of the
creature and it persists over
evolutionary time right complex it has
an expense and it persists of
evolutionary time and my point is
if it were not
producing a benefit to that organism
that exceeds that cost than over
evolutionary time it would be eliminated
right and we wouldn't see it instead
what we saw is a whole clade of
organisms different species that had
these things which says that some
organism that had less of one uh was not
out competing those that had had more of
them
so here's the reason that I like this
nipple question
the nipple question passes the male
nipple question passes the Adaptive test
right
it's not hugely expensive but it is an
expense nipples are made out of material
that material does not have an obvious
benefit in males but there's a
complexity to it that material and
energy that goes into producing a male
nipple could be redirected into other
Fitness enhancing behaviors or
structures and so what the hell is going
on given that male nipples are not
useful in the feeding of Offspring why
would selection not have economized
these things out of existence long ago
now here's the hypothesis which I I have
come to believe very strongly is likely
to be true but needs a test
the hypothesis is that if you have a
mechanism if you built into human beings
or to uh any
mammal if you built in a mechanism an
ethereum that would remove nipples when
the male physiology program had been
triggered anytime something was going to
be a male you Econo economized away the
nipples then what you've got is a
mechanism that turns nipples off
once you've got a mechanism that turns
nipples off a it can go wrong
occasionally a female who is otherwise
reproductively capable will lack nipples
and her children will presumably starve
um and B it creates a target for some
let's say plant that you're eating to
disrupt if it wants if it sees you as a
parasite and uh is looking to reduce the
level of parasitism can it disrupt that
pathway now that that pathway exists so
the hypothesis is that the pathway is so
dangerous where milk production is
essential to the raising of offspring
that
selection has built in a resistance to
economizing it away
so that no female is born without
nipples and therefore those Offspring
Don't Starve for the lack of the ability
to feed them early in in childhood
now again this is a hypothesis it is not
it has not survived a test so far as I
am aware
I will say a valid scientific hypothesis
requires a
test it at least needs to be testable in
principle hopefully in practice but at
least in principle to be a valid
hypothesis something like let's say oh I
don't know String Theory which doesn't
provide a mechanism for testing it is
not even not only is it not a theory
it's not even a hypothesis right it
becomes a hypothesis at which it makes a
test so in this case there may be better
tests I may come up with something more
elegant and easier to accomplish but I
would say the correct test that I spot
is if it is true that selection has
actively protected nipples from being
removed in males because of the danger
that it would pose in females to have
such a pathway
then we will find
that there is a protective mechanism in
other words the degree to which
different genes are exposed to
experimentation evolutionary
experimentation varies there are some
genes that are highly experimental
because they're involved in arms races
and there are other genes that are very
conservative because disrupting them
creates a Cascade of bad effects I would
argue that we will find that the genes
involved in the production of nipples
have been given uh that protective
characteristic that prevents
experimentation with their elimination
developmentally and that that is why we
see them right and in fact that would be
the Adaptive feature right the nipples
would be a manifestation of that
adaptation which has moved nipples out
of the experimental category into a
highly conserved category of the genome
and served it's not it's not exactly a
question of low evolvability but it's a
it's about
um a sort of a separate kind of uh
conservatism around what could be
changed it's it's hard to operationalize
them in part because we don't there's so
many possible mechanisms by which that
might happen but um the prediction
then that you are making for your
hypothesis is that there will be
something
to be to be specified upon discovery
that is uh that is
producing lower rates of change in those
genes than in adjacent other otherwise
comparable genes that do something else
yeah I wouldn't say adjacent because one
of the things that happens is that genes
have moved around the genome to protect
them from experimentation I would point
out though in thinking about this this
morning this is what I'm really arguing
for is the inverse of what I have
elsewhere called an Explorer mode right
Explorer modes are places where
Evolution looks around design space for
Solutions at a in a direct way this is a
place where such experimentation is
reduced and it creates a kind of genetic
sacredness or uh some other kind it
creates a you know a taboo around
genetic experimentation but in any case
that's the basic hypothesis
all right
the reason that I raise that hypothesis
this has to do with something that uh I
at least ran across yesterday which is
the cdc's entry in its glossary page
Zach do you want to show it
okay so here is this is on the cdc's
site Center for Disease Control in their
glossary I think I can read it
so the glossary has three entries that
I'm showing here
breastfeeding the practice of feeding an
infant or young child breast milk
directly from the breast also see chest
feeding nursing
and then next entry breast milk slash
human milk right breast milk is no
longer sufficient
milk produced by the human mammary
glands to feed infants and young
children breast milk and human milk can
be used interchangeably
and then third is chest feeding a term
used by many masculine identified trans
people to describe the act of feeding
their baby from their chest regardless
of whether they have had chest slash Top
surgery to alter or remove mammary
tissue I mean that's not even I mean
that's
terrible but that's not even complete I
mean because the story this week was
this
I think because this dude has been on
estrogens who's uh been
feeding whatever thing is coming out of
his nipples this baby right and so
anyway my point about the glossary
though is that what we've got is the CDC
so I I tweeted yesterday that 10 years
ago if hackers had breached the CDC
website's wall that they could have put
something this absurd on the cdc's page
uh you know as an act of as a prank as
an act of vandalism but that effectively
vandals have taken over the CDC right
yeah now there are a couple things worth
extrapolating from this
one
there is a game being played here
weeks ago we talked about the absurdity
of Chess feeding we collectively I don't
we also talked about it on Dark Horse
but we were talking about chest feeding
which at the time what we were talking
about were trans men these are people
born female who therefore have female
mammary glands feeding their offspring
and the suggestion slash coercion to
call this chest feeding
with the purpose of not offending such
people
and to call them fathers right now
that's insane yes however
you are at least talking about
biological females feeding infants with
female breasts and then we are talking
about what to call them right right and
that's what's in the glossary as well no
because the glossary
is
opening the door to whatever it is that
is being delivered
being considered feeding
can you show it to us again Zach
I hadn't I hadn't seen it before uh
milk produced by the human mammary
glands so
you know I don't know
I don't know what is coming out of that
guy's chest yeah but
even if he has had
fake boobs put on he doesn't actually
have mammary tissue well I don't
actually know do you know the
distinction in because well first of all
there is a case in bats yes in which
bats have been male bats have been shown
to lactate this is in the wild yes this
is presumably not the result of
disruption and remember what it's a
terrapoted which is a mega bat from the
old world a large fruit bat Blind Fox
yeah um and they have been observed uh
to lactate and actually to feed
Offspring I believe so the question is
whether or not breast tissue is
um
is
fundamentally different or whether it is
basically latent mammary tissue that can
be activated yeah I don't know yeah so
uh in any case the idea that the CDC is
broadcasting as if it is a scientific
conclusion this obviously political fact
and I would point out
with no
parent thought
to the impact on
the baby right this is the orientation
here across the board all of these
things
the you know the most defenseless
members of society of all are just being
completely disregarded
they're com and they're being
disregarded here at a couple of
different levels right we're talking so
breast is best right we have talked
about the logic of why that is true
right that's not a political assertion
that is a biological fact yes okay so
what we're talking about here is a case
in which there might be an argument that
breast is not best let's take the case
of a
um
a female to male trans person who has an
offspring right now that female to male
trans person is liable to be on
uh sex distorting hormones
so there is a question about whether the
disruption to the baby actually reverses
the normal logic of the superiority of
breasts right but I mean this this is
like saying we're going to fix the you
know fix some imagined or fix some real
ratio uh that we would like to fix in
college uh whereas all of the
Discrimination that may have happened
that led to that ratio happening with
the K-12 level
you're talking about someone who wants
to
who wants to feed their baby from their
body if they can do that it's because
they were gestating probably and that's
that's the even bigger issue right that
I mean you know no I don't think that if
you are a woman who is taking
testosterone because you're confused
about what sex you are that you should
be
um feeding a baby milk from your breast
but you definitely shouldn't have been
gestating for nine months either and
frankly like over and over and over
again you know you've got at the at the
just really really broad brush level
you've got two kinds of effects of
hormones and I've said this before and
it's much more complicated than this but
somehow even this level of different
kinds of effects is missing from all of
the trans ideologues arguments
activational effects of for instance
testosterone are those that have an
effect in the moment and at the point
that you stop being on the testosterone
those effects will disappear
organizational effects
have effects that lay down Pathways that
establish
anatomical and physiological realities
that even if later the testosterone
stops the effects of it do not they
effectively organized hence
organizational effects organized your
body your shape your physiology your
anatomy in an irreversible way
if you have been on testosterone as a
woman and you decide oh I actually want
to become a mother and you won't call it
that because you're that kind of
confused but I you know I want to
um gestate a baby and maybe you have one
of the better but still frankly should
be criminal gender doctors who says oh
well you should at least go off the
testosterone while you're pregnant
still
what is having been on testosterone
um what are the effects of that going to
be on your pregnancy and once you're not
pregnant anymore presumably you're just
allowed to go back on it and then you're
feeding that directly to your kid so I
none of this is good for the child so
this was this is the point I want to get
yeah
the most fundamental thing you in our in
our book we talk about
um love we talk about what it is and the
most fundamental kind of love the
elemental kind from which all of the
others are derived is maternal love of
Offspring right yeah in mammals that's
where it starts right now
the problem is
let's say that you were
um born female and you feel that you're
um
your sex is at odds with your body
well
you are
either
in a position that that is your priority
in which case you should not be
producing Offspring because actually
this is inconsistent with the well-being
of your Offspring and your obligation as
a mother is to your Offspring
fundamentally fundamentally and so the
point is maybe you're born female you
feel male and you say you know what
maybe I feel male but my parental
obligation supersedes that right and I'm
going to just suck it up and deal with
the the dysphoria and I'm gonna live as
a female right and I'm going to do right
by my Offspring or
the point is actually I can't live like
this in which case oh then don't have a
kid right because the point is what do
you mean you feel male and you want to
have a baby right like no that's
inconsistent one and B your obligation
is to the baby right parents sacrifice
for Offspring period the end that's what
Parenthood is and if you can't sacrifice
if you choose not to be a parrot right
and do but once you've chosen to be a
parent
that is your priority
right now this then raises that other
issue that you were talking about uh
which I don't guess we don't have a
screenshot of but this person
um this male who had quote unquote
transitioned to female who was nursing
an offspring and I could find it I don't
know I don't know if we want to see it
or not but yeah well in any case uh
people can certainly
conjure the idea of a person a born male
uh
transitioned to female nursing a child
or nursing is the wrong term but
engaging in behavior that
looks like nursing with a child
and
give a thought for a moment to
yeah do you wanna understand that yeah I
don't know you don't think so I don't
know I don't I don't I don't
yeah I I don't I don't think anything
about this person is um
same yeah no it well it's insane
and Maybe not maybe not and actually
here here's the reason we mustn't I
would argue
that baby
is going to grow up and face a world in
which people have looked at this image
and politicized it yeah and
that baby did nothing wrong that baby
did nothing wrong they have been harmed
by a society that has rules against
uh people gratifying them sexually with
children
right very important rules fundamental
rules for a reason right and then we
have somebody engaged in some kind of
pantomime a man
hearing to nurse a baby
uh
um
with no thought to what the impact on
that baby will be not only of the
behavior itself but of the fact of uh
having been observed in this person's
self-gratification at whatever level it
existed I mean it's it's the reveal that
there's no parenting going on that
parenting uh needs to have a
selflessness at its core a recognition
that it's not all about you anymore and
at some point it will become entirely
not about you and entirely about your
your child and and you have to
prioritize them
and instead what we are doing now is
um reveling in narcissism reveling in
selfishness
and in well I feel like this and
therefore I get to have what I want
that's just not the way either reality
or reality works or Society is supposed
to work and Society isn't working but
it's increasingly the way that Society
is being forced to sort of chug along
until it finally dies
so I want to connect the two topics that
we've covered yesterday there's a
behavior that I would call uh I don't
know getting your foot in the door okay
so weeks ago and literally it was weeks
ago we were discussing the absurdity of
chest feeding in the form that somebody
born female transitions to male and then
breastfeeds an offspring and that we
have to call it chest feeding for some
reason right yeah
that is an absurdity at the linguistic
level right it is a tiny fraction of the
absurdity of the at the biological level
of a person-born male who then
pantomimes
breastfeeding even if they're leaking at
the breast somehow because of some
hormone they've been taking yeah there's
some drugs apparently that can promote
such discharge they can promote a
discharge but the point is that ain't
feeding right but my point is once you
carve out the idea that oh
we used to say breastfeeding but that's
disrespectful to some fraction of the
population we must now call it chest
feeding in order not to disrespect
certain people oh you're calling it
chest feeding hey guess who else has a
chest right now you've got some dude
leaking at the breast right
photographing himself and the point is
oh well you you said you're okay with
chest feeding how is this not chest
feeding and the point is ah you got your
foot in the door with people born female
who want to nurse children and don't
want to have it called breastfeeding
because it's disrespectful and now you
got dudes doing it you got your foot in
the door and then you keep the thing
wide open here's the connection to the
other topic
the GMO
industry Monsanto in particular created
a market for itself with Roundup Ready
crops yep right Roundup Ready crops are
crops that have been engineered to
tolerate an herbicide that weeds cannot
tolerate right that's the technology
that technology involves
spraying this stuff early in the life
cycle of crops yep right that gives it's
not safe but it gives a lot of time for
the thing to degrade in the sun it gives
a lot of time for it to be washed off
the plant so that at the point that you
eat you know if you sprayed it on early
so that the plant erupts from the soil
gets a jump on the weeds
and then it doesn't you know once it's a
mature plant it doesn't need that jump
on the weed so you're not spraying it
late and then you know a cucumber
emerges from the vine right the point is
how much of that herbicide does the
Cucumber have
some it shouldn't that's bad but it's a
tiny fraction of what would happen if
you sprayed it on the Cucumber now
here's the point
Roundup Ready crops
got GMOs
through the door and the particular
Roundup compound into the agricultural
space yeah at which point
it was discovered that it could be used
as a desiccant that's right and you
could spray it on wheat when do you do
that oh at the end after the wheat is
dead right so that it doesn't get mold
you keep it dry by spraying around up on
it well wait
you just sprayed it on something we're
going to eat it's like it's not it's the
opposite of the Cucumber where the
Cucumber didn't get sprayed because the
plant was early in its life cycle when
you did the spring and now you're
spraying it on something we're actually
going to grind up and turn into loaves
of bread right who said that was safe
the point is in the mind you kick the
door open with Roundup Ready crops and
then the point is what's the same
compound you said we could spray it on
the on the crops right so now we're
going to spray it on the freaking weed
and you know it's like
okay
chest feeding by someone born male is
linguistically
twice as dumb as chest feeding by
somebody born female who's transitioned
to male it is biologically two hundred
thousand times as dumb yeah right this
is the same thing spraying Roundup on
your cucumber patch early before there
are any cucumbers
that's dumb yeah spraying it on wheat at
the end of its life cycle to keep mold
from growing on it that will be turned
into the bread that you eat yeah that's
orders of magnitude more dumb but the
point is you kick the door open you know
after you got your foot in and the point
is mentally it didn't seem that
different so whatever that's how it
happened
yeah how are you how are you going to
stop it there's so many things to worry
about just
just trust them no I know there's
Roundup I know it's not good oh
it's not one thing you just you're doing
two totally different things right yeah
um you know it's like the difference
between you know uh a glass of water and
a lake
you probably could drown on a glass of
water but you're more likely to drown on
a lake I think moderns would be more
capable of drowning in a glass of water
than people hundred years ago
MIB yeah totally I think we're we're
creating among many other uh
disabilities the ability to drown in
amazingly small bodies of water
that seemed to be what we're working up
towards
uh is there to think we can okay can we
make this a little bit more upbeat
before we like we're not going to be
back for a week and a half and this is
terrible I mean this yeah just like
everything here that like that
the endocrine disruption that we are
doing across the board and
um
it was a terms of the atrocene is an
herbicide
um it's not explicitly targeting an
endocrine system of another animal but
there's plenty of actual toxins that we
are spraying on things in order to get
at the so-called pests you know the
pesticides that are actually endocrine
disruptors that we are also just you
know spreading across our landscape into
our soils into our water and oh we can't
evade it and
and the New York Times takes a mocking
tone and says there's no evidence that
that even yeah it messes with frogs but
there's no evidence they could have
possibly have any effect on humans
guys ever thought scientifically for
half a second
like in any way do you in fact believe
in evolution you claim to be the ones
who were all about Evolution I don't
think you understand a damn thing yeah
well anything this is this is a this is
a basic failure uh of our educational
system and you know it comes at
different levels but
you know we meet people all the time I
wasn't good at biology well I know what
happened to you yeah you had a bad
biology teacher who didn't know what
they were doing and they tried to make
you memorize the Krebs cycle or they
overly focused on you know yes kingdom
phylum Etc yeah memorization memorize
the 20 minutes right memorize the
memorized it's boring and it contains to
do that no power and you probably didn't
get a good grade and you felt like you
weren't good at doing biology but the
result of all of that is that people do
not a they are denied the benefit of
understanding what they even are right
you're a walking miracle in a world of
other Miracles and you you in order to
appreciate that fully you need to
understand the biology and even better
if you understand that that Miracle came
about without a miracle worker right
yeah
um
so
people are denied that value which is a
tragedy but it is also
it is mentally crippling because you do
not Intuit the degree to which your body
is capable of dealing with all of these
insults but
the cost of the insults is massive and
you know again back to the the idea of
what happens if you stand in an airport
and just watch people walk by and ask
yourself how healthy do they look right
how many people have to pass by before I
see somebody and say actually that
person is just attractive in the sense
that we used to mean it right
um you know we are paying a huge price
for things that we don't see in the New
York Times and all of its you know petty
little companions in the what used to be
called journalism
are still beating the same drum yeah
where it's you can't prove that's what
did the harm it's like okay but why
aren't you interested in what did right
precisely
precisely we've got a rise in
all of the indicators of poor human
health
and
there is
very little
evidence for any one particular thing
that has changed in the 20th century
being the cause for any of them because
how could there be because everything
changed at once
but what we did do was we started
spraying our lands and filling our water
and filling our bodies with a bunch of
chemicals many of which are actually
known to be endocrine disruptors and
reproductive
reproductive development halters and
Chaos agents and
unfortunately it's worse than that one
of these things yeah it's always worse
than that one of the things that we do
touch on in our book and I think is
eventually going to become a much
broader field
is
there are all sorts of things that are
capable of doing biological damage that
do not come in the form of a physical
interference or physiological disruption
at the chemical level right like light
levels like noise pollution right that
there is a kind of disruption that you
can do to a biological organism that
hyper novelty basically exists
throughout a wide spectrum of possible
mechanisms of interference that we do
not into it when you flip a light switch
you do not feel like you could be doing
anything that could do biological damage
right are you telling me that being
exposed to light does biological damage
it does informational damage yeah right
what we can see
is only a tiny fraction of what the
Spectrum the electromagnetic spectrum is
and uh we feel
vaguely unconsciously subconsciously
after a long time inside that
something's not quite right but we can't
see the difference with sunlight with
some light we can even see it but for a
lot of light we can't see it but we feel
it our health our health is effective
well but not only that you've got the
difference in the Spectrum which has
been edited down to that which you can
directly perceive because that's what
causes you to buy the bulb you know in
the shop we've got the frequency of the
flickering which you can't see but has
impacts we've got the implication about
what time of day it is based on the
spectrum of the light there are all
kinds of ways that electric light can be
destructive and we don't Intuit it
because we tend to think uh of
creatures
with the partially correct analogy to
machines right lots of people say oh
we're not machines we're not computers I
actually think we we are we are not
machines in the narrow sense of a car
but we are we are uh aqueous machines
and computers
and fantastically I mean self-building
right okay you're a machine but you're
also a self-building machine right how
easy is it I don't like the word machine
here I know but
um but the
at the basic point is our intuitions are
crappy over what can possibly do damage
and that has made it very easy for
people who have a perverse incentive to
get in the road of establishing that
actually there's a kind of harm that is
uh indirect but profound
um and that's where we are as we're
having the same argument again and again
where the people with the perverse
incentives are in a position to
overwhelm our ability to establish that
actually this is bad for us
yep
yep I don't know what to say to make it
to to bring us back up before we thought
that was pretty uplifting no you didn't
all right maybe I didn't even the dog is
disgusted it's like I'm out of here yeah
when I got set and bark at something and
greatest invention yeah can I go bark at
the CDC please yeah they won't listen
though
um all right we are going to take a
15-minute break and then uh come back
with a short probably today live q a ask
questions at darkhorseimmissions.com
where then we're going to be gone for a
week and a half come back on Wednesday
July 19th 11 30 a.m Pacific
and we'll be doing a watch party which
is where the chat will the chat like
thing will be happening from now on on
locals so join us there
um and find us lots more places
including we will have another guest
episode coming out um before our next
live stream and you're right here at
Dark Horse by of course right at natural
selections.substack.com we have Trader
subscriptions up for for Brett Twitter
subscriptions which are almost
impossible to see so you have to go
looking for it
um so anyway please do that
we have darkhorsestore.org with uh
various awesome merchandise psyop until
proven otherwise
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
um wiser the breakthroughs never stop
some of the things that you can find
there at darkhorsestore.org shirts bags
stickers all the things we of course
have this book which we talked about
some today Hunter gathers guide to 21st
century available everywhere and you can
get signed copies at darvel's here in
the San Juan Islands on Orcas and they
of course have a website too so you can
order signed copies from them
and we are going to begin to encourage
people on our patreons to go over to
locals um but we are not going to shut
down our patreon so
um we we're going to have
um a last private q a um based out of my
patreon this month on the last Sunday of
the month and then we're gonna hopefully
try to encourage everyone to go there
but um to go to locals
um but we've got on our patreons access
to the Discord Channel we've got um at
the higher tier levels access to
conversations that you have on the first
Saturday and Sunday of every month
and lots of great conversations people
around the virtual campfire talking and
and agreeing and disagreeing and
everything in between
non-toxic
hypoallergenic grass-fed
conversations
I can't promise that actually you can't
no no I can't all right
um I promise
thank you
once again check out our wonderful
sponsors this week that was paleo Valley
MD hearing and uncrews links look for in
the show notes and we are supported by
you we appreciate you subscribing liking
sharing we've got this channel here at
Rumble we've got YouTube uh and of
course if you listen on Spotify or
anywhere else
um you know that we appreciate your
appreciation and that if you hear
something that particularly resonates do
share it with someone who you think
would appreciate it or benefit from it
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank you